from the financial crisis
to brexit
to covid
and now the russian invasion of ukraine
it sometimes feels like we're living
through one economic shock after another
today came news of the latest the bank
of england sounding a recession warning
predicting a sharp fall in gross
domestic product at the end of the year
a dramatic drop in our national income
and even as households are squeezed the
bank added to the pain by raising
interest rates to 1
the highest level in 13 years you are
making life tougher for families right
now aren't you well what would make it
even tougher for families as if
inflation kept on rising even more i
mean i have to be honest about that
that's a risk that is a risk and it
would be even
that would be even tougher so we have to
take that into consideration the word
historic has been bandied around a lot
recently but consider this this is
inflation the consumer price index going
back 40 years the bank's latest
forecasts see inflation going up to 10
and a quarter percent the first time
britain has had double-digit inflation
since 1982. you're already talking about
inflation getting up to over 10
the highest level since the early 80s
as the governor you know it's your job
to try and keep it close to two percent
i mean how does that feel seeing it sky
high it's extremely uncomfortable i
don't want to make any bones about it
but the fact of the matter is this we
are being struck by
historically large shocks
i mean let's face it who you know who of
us thought there would be a war in
europe of the sort that we're seeing is
terrible
and that war says the bank is what turns
a serious price shock into a severe
price shock with economic implications
now strictly speaking the bank isn't
forecasting a technical recession
because the technical definition of
recession is two successive quarters of
contraction the economy's shrinking what
they're talking about is one fall then
little rise then little rise then
another four but in a sense that's
beside the point because what they're
talking about is real economic pain pain
in your pocket the kind we haven't felt
for a generation the message is if you
think things feel bad now
just wait till the winter
[Music]
this is the irresistible logic of an
energy price shock which pushes pretty
much all prices higher and makes it
harder to get hold of stuff a case in
point this apartment complex in london
it was supposed to be finished by now
but it's running months behind schedule
because of the difficulty in sourcing
materials the materials they've got are
much more expensive across the board so
you know obviously energy prices are
rising so anything that uses oil within
it will be going up in value but we've
seen energy prices for everything from
plasterboard steel has almost doubled
can you remember another time like this
no not as bad as this
with the sun shining and high streets
still pretty busy there's something
quite unreal about all of this it
doesn't feel like a recession yet
but if the bank's right the pain
is yet to come
ed conway sky news